these days any person has the
opportunity to follow the progress
being made by mankind in space
exploration
thanks to numerous scientific
investigations we've found
out that the universe is unbelievably
enormous
and contains a great number of celestial
objects
however in all this diversity there are
only several hundred worlds that we know
of
which resemble our planet in the milky
way alone
the number of exoplanets is supposedly
over a trillion
and now i invite you on a journey to the
most amazing
exoplanets ever discovered by now
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
[Applause]
the first exoplanets were discovered
back in the late 1980s
since then the number of detected ones
has increased hundredfold
according to statistics from january
over 4 000 planets in other systems have
already been discovered
apart from these several thousand
candidates likely to be given the status
have been registered
with sufficient evidence from
earth-based observatories
most of them are going to become
officially confirmed exoplanets
the overall number of planets in our
galaxy may supposedly be
over one trillion from five to twenty
percent of these are close to our earth
in terms of their size and composition
not all of them are in their host stars
godilog
zones that is not all of them are
habitable
still according to scientific estimates
there are not less than 300 million
potentially habitable planets in the
milky way
exoplanets differ very much in terms of
their environment
their dimensions may be enormous some
even beating jupiter
but there are also comparatively smaller
ones close to our earth and size
some of these bodies are hot consumed
with oceans of molten lava
whereas others are encased in a shell of
permanent ice
there are planets out there made
entirely of oceans
with not a bit of dry land on them while
in others
sulfuric acid drains or diamond snow are
irregular occurrence
various techniques are used for
discovering other worlds
as a rule it is next to impossible to
spot an exoplanet by simply looking
through a telescope
that is why in 2009 kepler was launched
the first space telescope designed for
searching for planets beyond the
boundaries of the solar system
the telescope's cameras had 42
charge-coupled devices
or ccds with a total resolution of
around 96 megapixels
with a field of view covering about 25
percent of the sky
and coupled with a one and a half meter
mirror of the telescope
it was able to detect astronomical
bodies within three thousand light years
from the earth
in the three and a half years of
productive operations
kepler managed to spot over three and a
half thousand
exoplanet candidates the status of over
000 of these has already been confirmed
by repeated observations
it was in this period that the smallest
of known exoplanets today was detected
the diameter of kepler-37b is just 35.7
percent that of the earth
the telescope was also instrumental in
registering several stars and brown
dwarfs
the transit method was used by kepler in
the search for exoplanets
this method is based on observing the
star's luminosity
if the supposed planet passes between
the parent star and the observer
this will be noticed in the telltale
decrease in the star's luminosity
the extent of these fluctuations in
luminosity
directly depends on the ratio of the
stars and planets dimensions
while their regularity allows one to
estimate the object's orbital period
the transit method requires accuracy in
measurements
changes in a star's spectrum account for
less than two percent
and are usually tenths or even
hundredths of one percent
ripples in the atmosphere dust and
precipitations
negatively affect results produced by
earth-based telescopes
that is the reason why telescopes based
on automatic space stations are used for
searching for objects
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system
unfortunately in 2013 three and a half
years into the mission
the kepler space telescope had several
major equipment failures
in 2018 the spacecraft ended science
operations completely
kepler was the first spacecraft to be
created specifically for looking for
exoplanets
however most of the objects it managed
to spot happen to be too remote and dim
to study them in any satisfying detail
that is why the next space research
complex had slightly different
parameters
kepler was succeeded by the test
telescope launched by nasa on the 18th
of april 2018
its main object was searching for rocky
exoplanets
orbiting the brightest stars within 200
light years from the sun
this telescope also used the transit
method
and here is the spacecraft's brief
profile tess is equipped with four
refractors with a 24 by 24 degree field
of view
and a 10 centimeter aperture the
spacecraft's peculiar
orbit allows it to cover both the
northern and the southern parts of the
sky
which is approximately 85 percent of the
entire sky
photos are taken by four cameras and the
resolution of each camera's ccd
is 16.8 megapixels
toi 700d is one of the most
notable objects discovered by tess
this exoplanet became the first object
of the kind
comparable to the earth and size and
which found itself in the habitable zone
of its star
it orbits toi 700 a red dwarf
lying slightly over a hundred light
years away from the sun
it is a small and rather cold star its
temperature is half that of the sun
and its mass and radius are just 40
percent those of the sun
toi 700 is peculiar for its high
stability
not a single flare has been registered
on it since the beginning of
observations
a star's stability is a positive feature
because bursts of activity are able to
divest its planets of their atmospheres
and be generally pernicious for
potential life on planet surfaces
there are at least three planets
orbiting toi 700
the one closest to it toi 700b
is comparable to the earth in size its
mass
is approximately 1.07 times that of our
planet
and its radius differs from that of the
earth by not more than two percent
unfortunately toi 700b is too close to
its host star
it is within about 0.06 astronomical
units
and a year on the planet lasts just 10
days
in addition to that chances are it is
tidally locked
that is it faces the star with one in
the same side
this means that the planet is likely to
be scorching hot
the planet lying further from its star
toi
700c is thought to be a mini neptune
its mass may be from 5 to 13 times that
of our earth
and its radius is 2 or 3 times that of
the earth
it takes toi 700c 16
days to complete one orbit around its
host star
located closer to the star than the
inner border of the habitable zone
it must be too hot for life to originate
and evolve there
toi 700d is the third
and at this point the remotest planet in
the system discovered by now
it takes 37.4 days to complete a full
orbit
which by the way lies along the inner
edge of the habitable zone
the mass of toi 700d hasn't been gauged
precisely
and may be anything from one to three
times that of the earth
at the same time the planet's radius is
just 20 to 30 percent bigger than that
of the earth
toi 700d is thought to be a rocky world
but its exact composition is not yet
known
the amount of energy received by the
planet from its star
is 86 that of the amount we receive from
the sun
assuming the planet's atmosphere is
similar to ours the steady state
temperature on the surface of toi 700d
is estimated at 268.8 kelvin
or 4.3 degrees celsius below zero
however due to the greenhouse effect or
other features of the atmosphere we may
not know yet
this figure may shift either up or down
there is no precise data on the
eccentricity of toi 700d but it is
thought to be small
at around point eleven as the planet's
orbit finds itself at the inner edge of
the goldilocks zone
the planet's eccentricity however small
may incidentally turn out to be
perceptible when the planet comes too
close to its star from time to time
thus actually leaving the habitable zone
still with the year on the planet
lasting slightly over one earth month
such unfavorable periods are expected to
be rather short
if there are living creatures on toi
700d
then they might be able to weather the
harsh spells in a state of anabiosis
alternatively they could adapt or
migrate to less inclement
areas even though the data acquired by
spectral analysis of toi 700d
can't be enough for making conclusions
there is a chance that there is liquid
water on the planet's surface
then there is bound to be the greenhouse
effect too
which will help the surface temperature
to reach favorable values
as i've already mentioned toi 700d
along with the other known planets in
the system is highly likely to be
tidally locked to its star
if this is the case there should be a
stark difference in temperatures between
the sunny side and the shadow side
this contrast could be leveled off by
dance atmosphere
but that would cause powerful hurricane
winds
although the main mission of tess has
been accomplished by now
it still has enough resources to carry
on operations
the telescope will continue taking
snapshots of the sky
including the milky way plane which is
the most challenging direction for
observation
over 2 100 exoplanet candidates have
been discovered by tess in the course of
the main mission
not less than 66 of them have already
been confirmed
apart from that six supernovae flares
have been registered
three exo comets identified and a great
number of photos taken of small bodies
in the solar system
the latters were not objects of the main
mission but are of course of scientific
interest
toi 700d is still guarding its mysteries
and waiting for its explorers great
hopes are placed on the new orbital
telescope james webb
which may help investigate this world
and a number of other ones
the new telescope is supposed to provide
images of not only exoplanets lying
closest
but also detect their moons and carry
out spectral analysis of their surfaces
the launch of the telescope is planned
for the 31st of october 2021.
if all goes according to plan first data
will be available as soon as next year
will we ever discover a world that could
rightfully be called the second earth
and if we do will we be able to reach it
distances in space are just too much for
humans
could it be that we're confined to the
limits of our system forever
allowed only to gaze at the vast
infinite universe
several centuries ago it was quite
unimaginable to admit of discovering
exoplanets
however everything changed in 1992 as
the polish astronomer alexander vostin
was studying the pulsar psr 1257 plus 12
it was noticed that its pulsation period
was irregular
which was accounted for by the influence
of two planets with a mass
four times that of our earth this
hypothesis was later confirmed
which led to the conclusion that the
first planetary system beyond
ours had been discovered there are three
objects in that system
two of which have a mass similar to that
of the earth and are comparatively close
to their pulsar in the constellation
virgo
due to the fact that it is rather remote
from us and the conditions for
sustaining life are poor
the psr-1257 plus 12
system is of little interest to
scientists although its discovery led us
to believe
that the search for earth-like worlds
may eventually be a success
just three years later the first
exoplanet orbiting a sun-like star was
discovered
50 light years away from the earth and
was dubbed
51 pegasi b just
several years later the number of
confirmed
exoplanets counted dozens and today
4173 exoplanets
in 3096 different planetary systems
unknown to science in addition a great
number of earth-like objects
is still awaiting the confirmation of
their status
which is possible after a secondary
registration with telescopes on earth
the number of celestial objects of this
kind in the entire milky way
may well be over a hundred billion with
about one-fifth of them
bearing resemblance to our earth
interestingly
most of the discovered earth-like
exoplanets
are located not very far from our system
ros128b this planet
was discovered in 2017 by european
scientists with the help of the high
accuracy radial velocity planet
searcher or halves at the observatory in
chile
the object is located in the single star
system ros 128
which is the 13th closest star to us
the object is a faint red dwarf with a
mass of 0.15 that of the sun
it was possible to discover this planet
thanks to its gravity
which leads to minor variations of the
stellar spectrum of its parent star
while observing these variations harps
is able to spot planets around stars
in this particular case it took the
telescope approximately 10 years to
collect sufficient data
before discovering this planet this
effort
paid off ros-128b
became the second earth-like exoplanet
lying closest to us
it is located 11 light years away from
the earth
in the constellation virgo apart from
that
astronomers claim it to be the most
moderate of all known exoplanets
due to its mass its temperature and
its rather calm parent star it takes
this planet 10 days to orbit its star
it finds itself in the habitable zone
since the temperature of the photosphere
and luminosity of ros 128
are low it is also classified as an
earth-like type of planet
and at the moment ros 128 b
is one of the most likely candidates to
be a potentially habitable exoplanet
besides research done in 2018 confirmed
that its climate is favorable enough to
sustain life
another exoplanet on the list of
earth-like objects located closest to us
is gliese 667cc
this celestial body is part of the
triple star stellar system gliese 667
in the constellation scorpius it
consists of two orange dwarves
and one red dwarf the first two
components
a and b lie 12.6 astronomical units from
each other with the third component
orbiting them at a distance of 230
astronomical units the earth-like planet
in this system
was discovered on november the 29th 2011
in the geneva observatory with the help
of the doppler method
the object is 22.7 light years away from
the earth
and is the second exoplanet orbiting its
host
star the mass of gliese 667cc
is about 3.8 times that of the earth
while its temperature range may be
rather similar to the terrestrial one
modeling at the planetary habitability
laboratory
managed by university of puerto rico
reveals
that the average surface temperature of
the atmosphere of gliese 667cc
must be approximately 27 degrees celsius
the planet receives about 90 percent of
energy
compared to that received by the earth
from the sun
also gliese 667cc is almost
certain to be locked in its orbit that
is it faces its star with one on the
same side
if the planet's orbit does not curve too
little and if its mass is not too big
the greenhouse effect produced by the
rather dense atmosphere
must be quite sufficient to create
favorable conditions
for primitive life forms
the next deserving object in our list is
hd85512b
an exoplanet orbiting the orange dwarf
hd85512
in the constellation velar its star
is a single k-type main sequence star
with the mass 0.69 that of our sun
as for its age it is more than 5.6
billion years old
the exoplanet discovered close to it
is located 36 light years away from the
earth
and its mass is 3.6 times that of our
planet
at the same time hd-85512b
may be one of the smallest planets in
the habitable zone
it was spotted in august 2011 with a
harps telescope
the supposed steady state temperature of
its surface
is something around 25 degrees celsius
if the planet's atmosphere is identical
to that of the earth
its surface temperature should reach 78
degrees
celsius it is also highly probable that
there is liquid water on this celestial
body
which is why for some time it was
believed to become the most
likely place where life would be
discovered first
apart from the objects mentioned there
is a number of other celestial bodies in
space
located quite close to us which also
boasts
some unique features many of them may
well contain
various life forms and maybe not quite
as far from us
as we would imagine however we should
bear in mind that some half a century
ago
man did not possess a tenth of
information known to us today
and in the future the progress of our
discoveries
is going to escalate even more
dramatically
for example on december the 18th 2019
the k-op space telescope was
successfully launched in orbit by the
european space agency
it is specifically aimed at exploring
exoplanets
using the transit method it may be this
spacecraft is to contribute to the list
of earth-like exoplanets
and it may become the telescope to first
discover alien life forms in the
universe
science does not stand still and every
new day
bears witness to the fact that mankind
continues to actively stride forward
if this progress does not lose its
momentum sooner or later we are bound to
find an answer to the eternal
mind perturbing question are we alone
in the universe and i hope the answer we
get will prove that
life is not a mere accident but a
logical consequence of the evolution
in our universe
[Applause]
the discovery of this object was made
with the kepler space telescope
whose mission was to look for exoplanets
the kepler star system became the 90th
object spotted by the telescope
that is where the catchy nickname
kepler-90 comes from
let's take a closer look at it kepler-90
is a yellow dwarf of spectral
type g0v both its mass
and radius are approximately 1.2 times
those of the sun
as for the surface temperature it equals
6080 kelvin
or 5800 degrees celsius
the estimated age of the star is 2
billion years
this makes it 2 times younger than our
sun which formed about 4.6 billion years
ago
it was possible to gauge the star's age
by analyzing its spectrum
which helps establish the stage of the
star's evolution
another method instrumental for the
purpose is observing stars lying closest
to the object under scrutiny
incidentally kepler-90 is too dim to be
seen with the naked eye
its luminosity meanwhile is
approximately 1.7 times
as intense as that of the sun located in
the draco constellation
it is approximately 2840 light years
away from our system
incidentally the object is hardly
notable for its properties
it is quite an ordinary main sequence
star without
any particularly exciting features it's
the number of planets discovered in its
system so far that makes it really stand
out
the only other system where we could
observe as many as eight planets had
been only our solar system
before kepler 90 had been spotted the
sun held the first place in terms of the
number of planets
with the following champions as the
runners-up the system's trappist-1
[Music]
hd10180 and hr-8832
each of them has seven detected planets
at first glance
kepler 90 might probably look like our
solar system in miniature
however on closer inspection the
following principal differences will
change the observer's mind about it
for a start the smaller planets are
closer to the star
with the bigger planets lying further
and following bigger orbits
as we know it's quite the other way
round in the solar system
with the giants close to the star and
the smaller planets located further away
admittedly it is too early to claim this
with absolute certainty
and the number of planets we know of in
the kepler system may increase
as scientists make progress in their
observations
another principal difference from our
system shows in the planet's mutual
proximity
the earth and the other planets in our
system on the other hand are located
further away from each other and also
all the eight known planets in the
kepler-90 system
orbit their star within just one
astronomical unit
another important difference is the fact
that six internal planets in the
kepler-90 system are either super
earths or mini neptunes in size while
its two outer planets
are gas giants the two planets in the
system lying closest to their host star
dubbed kepler-90b and kepler-90c
may probably be called our earth's
analogues however their temperatures are
considerably higher than on mercury or
venus
that is the two planets closest to their
host star in our solar system
this is the case on account of their
proximity to their system's center
kepler-90g and kepler-90h
are the objects lying furthest from
their apparent star
both of these bodies are gas giants
their dimensions must be comparable to
those of jupiter
the system leaves the general impression
of being extremely compact
even kepler-90h the remotest planet in
the system
lies approximately as far as the earth
does from the sun
also as i've already mentioned this
remotest planet
is also the largest in the system and a
year on it is almost as long as a year
on our earth
331 days to be more exact
all these planets were discovered not so
long ago
with the latest of them kepler-90i
spotted as recently as in 2017.
it was possible to detect it with the
transit method that is by observing
sharp
changes in the host's star's luminosity
when one or several planets pass across
its disk and block a certain portion of
its rays normally visible to us
this method is quite productive for
large celestial objects lying close to a
star
however if a planet is remote from it
fluctuations in the stars luminosity and
other incidental factors interfere with
observations
these problems may be dealt with in two
ways
namely by prolonging observation periods
and by sorting data with the help of
statistical algorithms and artificial
intelligence systems
in fact the latter helped the team of
scientists
studying kepler-90 in discovering the
eighth planet in the system
a specially trained neural network was
instrumental in pinpointing one more
planet in the kepler-90 system
and defining its parameters
the newly spotted object was given the
temporary designation
kepler-90i located between kepler-90c
and d this celestial object orbits its
star within less than 15 days
and its radius is 1.32 that of the earth
kepler-90i is three times closer to its
star than mercury is to the sun
that is why its surface temperature is
rather high
approximately 427 degrees celsius
just to compare this value is quite
close to the surface temperature
venus which is 477 degrees
celsius kepler-90i resembles our earth
very much in terms of its chemical
composition size
and mass its orbital period is 14.4
earth days
as the planet lies too close to its
parent star
it cannot realistically support life the
discovery of this celestial object
prompted a lot of questions on the part
of the scientific community
it still remains to be found out how
such a large and complex planetary
system
managed to remain so compact and stable
at the same time
also astronomers assume there might be
more planets out there orbiting
kepler-90
which still remain to be discovered the
search for other bodies in this system
is still on
as for the other known planets in the
system the parameters of each are unique
in their own way
let's have a look at them starting with
the planet closest to its star
the radius of the one nearest to its
parent star
kepler-90b measures about 1.3 times that
of the earth
and its orbital period lasts for seven
days
just like all the other objects in the
system except kepler-90i
it was detected back in 2013.
the planet coming next orbiting its
parent star slightly further away than
kepler-90b
is kepler-90c its radius is slightly
smaller
measuring 1.19 times that of the earth
and as for its orbital period it is 8.7
days
the fourth known object in terms of its
closeness to its star is kepler-90d
with its radius measuring 2.87 times
data the earth
it orbits kepler-90 within a period of
59.7
earth days kepler-90e
holds the fifth place its radius is 2.66
that of our planet
and its orbital period may reach 91.9
days
kepler-90f comes next
its radius is 2.88 times that of the
earth
and its orbital period is 124.9
earth days after kepler-90f
comes kepler-90g with a radius measuring
8.1 times that of the earth
its orbital period is 210.5 days
and its mass is approximately 0.8 times
that of jupiter
last but not least but definitely the
remotest from its star at this point
kepler-90h has a radius measuring 11.3
times that of the earth
its orbital period is 331.6
earth days and its mass is about 1.2
times that of jupiter
as this object's orbit lies
approximately as far from its star as
that of the earth from the sun
assumptions about the presence of
hypothetical moons in its environs may
prove to be true
if there are any located close to
kepler-90h
that are similar to titan or ganymede in
their parameters
conditions on these moons may be
realistically suitable for life
these hypothetical celestial objects
might have some really incredible
features as their planet lies in the
habitable zone of its star
some of these moons may well resemble
our earth
for all we know just as you are watching
this video on the cosmo channel
and your life may be dawning on a moon
of the far away gas giant
[Applause]
kepler-90h
is a kind of landscape one would see in
the least harsh part of a planet
dubbed by scientists as super earth and
the closest potential candidate suitable
for searching for alien life forms
but let's be consecutive
the recent past heralded a boom in
discovering exoplanets
there are 4 370 exoplanets discovered in
over 3 000
planetary systems so far in addition to
these
more than 3 000 objects are awaiting
confirmation of their exoplanet status
most of them are large bodies gas giants
super jupiters and super earths
this is accounted for by technical
features of the technologies used for
the purpose
it is easier to look for massive bodies
with a short orbital period than to try
to spot smaller planets similar to the
earth or mars in terms of dimensions
there are among exoplanets those that
may realistically harbor life
there are dozens of these objects
scattered in space
and they understandably draw scientists
close attention
today we're going to look at one of
these objects which is an exoplanet
dubbed gliese
832c in fact this exoplanet is one of
the most
likely places where alien life forms
will eventually be detected
this exoplanet orbits a star called
gliese 832
which lies 16 light years away from the
sun and is part of the gru's
constellation
gliese 832 is a dim red dwarf
whose luminosity is just 0.7 percent of
that of the sun
both its mass and diameter are
approximately two times smaller than
those of the sun
and its temperature reaches about 3300
degrees
kelvin that is the reason why the
habitable zone of this planet is within
quite a short range from its star
due to tidal forces the planets lying in
the habitable zone of gliese 832 will be
tidally locked to their star
that is will face the star with one side
only just as it is the case with the
moon and the earth
and mercury and the sun there are two
confirmed planets orbiting gliese 832
the jupiter-like planet glieser-832b
was discovered first astronomers
announced the event in 2008.
with the mass two-thirds out of jupiter
the planet orbits parents start a
distance of an average 3.4 astronomical
units
completing a full orbit every 9.4 earth
years
the discovery of the other confirmed
planet glieser 832c
was announced in 2015 by an
international team of scientists headed
by robert wittenmeier
it got an exceptionally high rating for
its similarity to the earth
0.81 to be more exact which instantly
attracted both scientists and reporters
it was also nicknamed the second earth
even though the two planets parameters
are rather different
either way this is one of the planets
closest to the earth with such a high
earth similarity index the mass of
glieser 832c
is five and a half that of the earth it
takes the planet
35 earth days to complete a full orbit
around its parent star
moving at a distance of an average 0.16
astronomical units
this is six times less than the distance
between our earth
and the sun its orbit's eccentricity is
rather high
with the planet regularly leaving the
habitable zone and then re-entering it
this must cause sharp temperature leaps
and drops on its surface
gliese 832c is estimated to receive
approximately as much energy flux from
its parent star as does the earth from
the sun
the average surface temperature on the
planet is 253 degrees kelvin or 20
degrees celsius below zero
it is also suggested that due to the
atmosphere which is likely to be quite
dense
the temperature on the planet may be
considerably higher
however it is not easy to claim this
with certainty as gliese 832c
lies quite close to its star and so
chances are it is firmly tidily locked
to it
in this case there should be a
substantial temperature difference
between its sunny side and shadow side
which should regularly cause hurricane
winds if the atmosphere really is
dense it's worth mentioning that in 2017
following observations astrophysicists
from the university of texas at
arlington the usa
put forward the hypothesis that there
may be a third planet in the glieser 832
system
its mass could be 1 to 15 earth masses
and it could follow a stable orbit
around the center of the system
0.25 to 2 astronomical units away from
it
at the moment the planet is being
searched for
let's imagine what gliese 832c would
look like
assuming life were possible on this
planet
first of all we wouldn't help noticing
its gravity
which would be strikingly higher than
that on our earth
since the planet's diameter is not yet
known the gravity force cannot be
calculated exactly
still it would be a rocky planet similar
to our earth and earth-like planets in
terms of its density
so its gravity force would be likely to
reach two to four hundred percent
that of the earth this would lead to the
relief leveling out
meaning that the mountains would not be
so high and the ocean is not so deep
this in its turn would enhance the area
of warm water which is favorable for
life
due to a dense atmosphere and a
comparatively dim sun
the landscape on gliese 832c would be of
a reddish hue
and in general the planet would be
submerged in semi-darkness
since the planet is likely to face its
star with the same side at all times
the temperature on the sunny side should
be high and the temperature on the
shadow side quite low
in the ring-like area at the border
between them the temperature should be
moderately
comfortable although due to regular
heating of the planet the atmosphere
would be constantly in turmoil
which should result in strong winds in
addition
high objects of relief potentially able
to dissipate some of the force of
hurricane air currents
fail to form on account of high gravity
conditions
as the orbit of gliese 832c is small and
elongated
seasons on this planet should change
every week it will be winter on gliese
832c at the furthest
point from its parent star and summer at
the closest approach
the tilt of the rotational axis with
respect to the ecliptic plane
will not be of such importance as it is
in the case of the earth
the change of season will depend
exclusively on the planets getting
closer to or away from its parent star
the most favorable conditions for life
to develop on gliese 832c
are likely to be in the ring-like area
at the border between the light and the
dark sides of the planet
it is here that most liquid water will
accumulate
and rain down from clouds formed on the
warm side
ice caps on the dark side will also melt
in the border zone
thus supplying still more water it goes
without saying that it is water that is
key to developing life
the change of seasons will be likely to
play the same role as lunatids on our
earth
with areas alternately submerging and
re-emerging
this process of water getting mixed with
substances dissolved in it
is a good prerequisite for life to
originate and develop
there is a good chance of life
originating in water and probably
staying in it without later spreading to
land
the ocean reduces the effect of gravity
and protects its potential inhabitants
from sharp temperature changes and
hurricane winds
as for frequent and sharp changes of
seasons hypothetical organisms on gleesa
832c
may learn to lapse into a state of
anabiosis in order to weather unpleasant
although short periods of high and low
temperatures
alternatively they may choose to
emigrate to a comfortable temperature
zone from the sunny side to the shadow
side and back
again for example if a space probe
ever reaches the surface of gliese 832c
to investigate the area what would it
see there
assuming life did originate on this
planet as the gravity forces are rather
strong there
the potential inhabitant should be a
thick set chunky figure
boasting a robust skeleton and powerful
muscles
plants on gliese 832c would be dark
in order to attract as much light as
possible
they should also be quite low and likely
to be creeping or moss-like
with strong roots able to stand winds
it is highly likely that rather than
chlorophyll some other molecules should
be important for photosynthesis
the planet's dense atmosphere may become
a habitat for bizarre life forms
floating in air currents
single-celled microorganisms for
instance may float in this dense
atmosphere following air currents
while capturing light and nutrients
dispersed in the air
because of a dense atmosphere high
clouds and a dim
sun the surface of gliese 832c would be
a rather dark
place life forms would have to adapt to
these conditions
vision would probably not play the
decisive role in their existence
if it evolved at all alternatively its
spectrum may be limited to the infrared
range
be it as it may all these speculations
remain conjectures and ideas
even though they're based on good
physical laws and assumptions
i wonder which of these suggestions you
would call realistic
and which of them bordering on fantasy
or perhaps
gliese 832c is not habitable at all
let us know in the comments and let's
keep in touch
this object is a single star with a
planetary system and there are at least
three celestial bodies within the
habitable zone
now let's look at it in more detail the
distance between trappist-1 and our sun
is 39 and a half light years
the object was discovered in the period
from 2016 to 2017.
this single star is a red dwarf of
spectral type
m8v as for its dimensions
it is only 12.1 percent of our sun's
radius
just to compare it isn't in fact much
larger than jupiter
the mass of trappist-1 is 27 000 times
that of our earth
but at the same time is 0.08 the mass of
our sun
with the average temperature reaching
2500 kelvins
its luminosity is 1900 times weaker in
comparison with that of the main star of
our system
the orbital period of trappist-1 is 3.3
days
as for its age it is seven and a half
billion years
which makes it almost three billion
years older than the sun
the distance between this star and us is
diminishing
as it is slowly but surely drifting
towards our system
this object aroused interest largely
following the discovery of its planetary
system
back in 2016 whose three components were
spotted by transit method with the help
of an automated 0.6 meter telescope in
the european southern observatory or the
eso
in chile the planets were initially
dubbed trappist-1b
trappist-1c and trappist-1d
however further investigations revealed
that the presumed location of
trappist-1d was described incorrectly
following that four more earth-like
objects were discovered by astronomers
with the help of the spitzer space
telescope
these were dubbed trappist a f g
and h thus the total number of planets
in the system reached seven
and on the 13th of april 2016 the
parameters of these celestial objects
were defined in more detail all the
seven exoplanets
are identical to our earth in terms of
their dimensions
with their radii ranging from 0.71
to 1.13 that of our planet planets b
and c orbit their parent star in the
periods of 1.51
and 2.42 days respectively
initially according to astrophysicists
both of these planets were comparable to
venus
in all but exceptionally high
temperatures
however after their mass and density had
been measured
it was trappist-1 that could be called
venus's analog
trappist-1b the second closest planet to
its star
is likely to contain a large amount of
water and other volatile elements
the new data enabled scientists to find
out more about the other discovered
planets too
it takes trappist-1d 4.05 days to orbit
its star
its radius is 0.77 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1e is 6.1
days
its radius is 0.92 that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 f may
last
up to 9.2 earth days its radius is 1.04
that of the earth
the orbital period of trappist-1 g is
12.3 days
and its radius is 1.13 that of the earth
last but not least trappist-1 h is the
seventh object
and is the furthest from its star with a
rotation period of 18 days
and a radius of 0.7 that of our planet
it should be mentioned that the initial
estimates of the object's masses were
likely to be rather conservative
due to the analysis of the density of
the first six planets
it was later ascertained that they
contain a big amount of water and other
volatile elements
which makes them considerably lighter
than thought previously
as for the furthest of them e f g and h
for all we know they may consist
entirely of water
only trappist-1c boasts a mass bigger
than initially estimated
which may be indicative of over 50
percent of iron in its composition
of the seven planets known to be located
in the trappist-1 system
three of them find themselves within the
habitable zone namely d
e and f speaking about the rest of them
following the estimates of its density
planet b is thought to contain either a
small nucleus
or else a considerable amount of
volatile elements
due to high temperatures of 127 and 69
degrees
celsius above zero on the surfaces of
planets b
and c respectively water is not likely
to remain in its liquid state there
and is bound to float about as vapor as
for planets g
and h they're too remote from their
central star to be potentially habitable
however according to models suggested at
cornell university
the habitable zone of trappist-1 may
well be wider
and allowing for volcanic hydrogen
potentially acting as a greenhouse gas
there may be four planets within the
habitable zone
rather than three the density of
trappist-1 f
is rather low too and so it may well
turn out to be an all-ocean planet
here are the temperatures for all the
planets in the system
the steady-state temperatures are given
without including incident light
dispersion
and greenhouse effects just to compare
the steady-state temperature on our
planet in the same conditions
would measure four degrees above zero
and on mars
47 degrees below zero
in november 2017 it was posited that the
activity of the star didn't allow its
planets to form and maintain their own
atmosphere
it is accounted for by the fact that
trappist-1 goes through periods of
active flares
which may negatively affect the nearby
celestial bodies
and thus render them uninhabitable for
living organisms as we know them
interestingly the planets are located
much closer to each other in comparison
to our systems planets
the planet mercury which is the closest
one to the sun
is located 0.39 astronomical units from
it
while the distance between trappist 1b
and its parent star
is just 0.01 astronomical units
as trappist-1 is a rather dim star it is
no easy matter to explore it
red dwarfs like that are quite
widespread across the universe
accounting for most of the galaxy's
stellar matter
plasma ejections on these stars are a
rare occasion
although astronomers believe that there
may be giant cold areas and compact hot
areas with temperatures upwards of 4 000
kelvins on the surface of trappist-1
if this conjecture proves to be true
scientists will proceed to confirm that
the system's planets are constantly
bombarded by powerful
ultraviolet and x-ray radiation which is
able to destroy their atmospheres
and render their surface completely
sterile
the reason for that lies in the fact
that none of the microorganisms known on
the earth are able to withstand
intensive radiation
emanating from flares of this kind
including the most radiation resistant
bacteria
dana caucus radiodurans
nevertheless in december 2017
atmosphere was proven to persist even in
periods of high activity of stars
which implies that planets g and h may
potentially have their own atmospheres
at the moment astrophysicists idea is to
use more up-to-date telescopes for
studying the matter
for example the james webb space
telescope whose launch is planned for
march 2021
today the trappist system presents a
great interest for the global scientific
community
and even though it is highly unlikely
that any advanced civilization will be
discovered on its planets
we cannot ignore the fact that life
forms in the universe may be extremely
diverse
and may differ from our perceptions of
life as we know it
which implies that not all intelligent
organisms are supposed to follow the
scenario of our planet
if science manages to find out more
details about this system in the nearest
decades
many conjectures and doubts we have
today about trappist-1
will most likely be cleared
[Applause]
systems with this number of stars are
rather rare
what we see while observing the stars
are generally binary systems
that is systems consisting of two
objects
as for multiple systems that is those
made up of three or more stars
they are by far rarer
there are two varieties of multiple
systems
namely optical and physical objects and
optical systems are located far from
each other
but seen from the earth they appear to
be just one star
objects and physical systems meanwhile
are actually close together
and are bound by gravity most physical
multiple systems consist of just three
objects
it is triple systems that account for
about 70 percent of all systems of this
kind
known to us today the caster system
however
is noticeably different from the
majority each of the three main stars in
this system is a binary star
thus the total number of stars in caster
is six
it is also highly unlikely that there is
stars in areas unobservable
to us in caster's vicinity which are
gravitationally bound to this sextuple
system
the more components a multiple system
contains the fewer such systems there
are in space
this means that systems consisting of
three and more stars must be extremely
rare in the universe
it goes without saying that we're far
from possessing all data about multiple
systems statistics
that is why we can't but admit that in
theory there may be systems with still
more components
somewhere in deep space getting back to
the caster system
this is the second brightest object in
the constellation gemini
it is beaten only by pollux an orange
hued giant star
in terms of luminosity in our sky caster
holds the 23rd
place the system is 50.88 light years
away from our earth and its age is
estimated at approximately 200 million
years
it was discovered back in the 17th
century and even then it was classified
as a binary system
and later astronomers managed to spot
several other objects physically bound
to it
the first and the main component of the
system was dubbed caster aa
this is a main sequence star of spectral
type a15
it is about twice as heavy as our sun
and its radius is also
two suns radii the surface temperature
on caster reaches approximately 9140
degrees kelvin
at the same time the object's luminosity
is 30 times that of our sun
the second component's designation is
caster ba
it is of spectral type a25m and its mass
is 1.7 times that of the sun with its
radius measuring 1.6 that of the sun
caster ba orbits its companion
starcaster a
a it takes the two objects about 350
years to complete a full orbit around
each other
it was later found that the eclipsing
variable star yy
geminorum is also physically bound to
caster
it is a star of spectral type m .55
a its mass is 0.62 that of the sun
and its radius is 0.76 that of the sun
that made it the third component in the
system so it was rightfully designated
caster ca this star follows an elongated
elliptical orbit around the system's
bary center
scientists estimate its orbital period
at 14
000 years as for its location it is
approximately 1
100 astronomical units away from its two
companions
each of these stars is binary which
means that each of them has a secondary
companion of its own
let's look at them caster a b
is strongly bound to caster a and its
mass is about half that of the sun
caster bb is a starved spectrotype
m25 and its mass is also about half that
of the sun
caster cb is a starved spectrotype
m .55e and is slightly heavier at 0.57
sun's mass
and with a radius of 0.68 that of the
sun
[Music]
caster cb is almost identical with
caster ca in its properties
as the surface temperature of both is
approximately 3820
degrees kelvin and their luminosity is
less than 10 percent that of the sun
all the six stars orbit around a common
center of mass
or barry center and their overall
luminosity is 52.4 times that of the sun
caster a a and caster ba are white stars
interestingly the former is 30 times and
the latter 14 times
brighter than the sun by contrast
castus ca and castus cb are typical red
dwarfs
according to scientists caster a a and
caster ba
are supposed to remain in the main
sequence stage for at least several
hundred million years
the red dwarves meanwhile like caster ca
and cb have a much longer expected
lifespan
this is due to the slow process of
thermonuclear fusion of hydrogen
and so they may last from several
billion to tens of trillions of years
scientists are currently busy looking
for exoplanets in the caster system
however so far they have not been able
to discover as much as a hint of
exoplanets in the system
perhaps the system is too young to have
produced any or else more advanced
methods of detection are called for
it is too early to speak about other
physical properties of these stars
it is quite difficult to study them
because they are optical doubles
and seen from the earth only seem to be
close whereas it is an illusion
that is why special spectrometers are
necessary to take care of accurate
measurements
we can see all the six stars from our
earth as a single object
and it is located in the northern
hemisphere in the constellation gemini
the best time to observe them is in
winter and spring
it is easy to locate cast in the sky as
it is bright enough
and can be found near a well-known
asterism called the winter circle
or the winter hexagon this asterism is
made up of pollux
capella aldebaran rigel
sirius and procyon it is best seen in
the night sky in northern latitudes in
the winter time
february is the best month to observe
caster and pollux
it's worth mentioning that caster is a
star system that leads a group of at
least 16 celestial bodies
the point is that these stars move
together and have similar velocities
and their rage is similar that is why
they have been dubbed by scientists as
the caster moving group
or cast a stream it includes such
well-known
astronomical objects as fomalhaut vega
alderamin alpha libri and others
the question of caster's stellar
evolution still remains open
as i've mentioned before most telescopes
are incapable of revealing finer details
of these stars
as they are too close together as seen
from the earth
according to some scientists systems of
this kind are formed as a result of a
big star split into two components by
centrifugal force
others claim that they originate when
one star gravitationally captures the
other
there is also a theory of compound
nucleus formation
that suggests a molecular clouds
fragmentation with stars forming as a
result
then there is a theory involving
proto-stellar discs
that suggests sudden cooling of gas in a
massive protostellar disk
so several stellar companions may
simultaneously originate in one and the
same plane
following the disk's fragmentation be it
as it may
most facts indicate that multiple
systems originate in one place
rather than from scattered sources in
the case of the caster system
its components are believed to have been
formed out of one molecular cloud
in the same period where a hypothetical
exoplanet
to find itself in the caster system its
inhabitants would have enjoyed rather
bizarre natural phenomena
for example the planet would receive
light from several stars at the same
time
so there would be several sunrises and
sunsets a day
at least it seems bizarre and exotic to
us as we live in the light of only one
star
if the sun had a companion with similar
parameters
the earth would get twice as much heat
and light with all that it implies
and the sky above us would have a
totally different aspect
and it is hard to imagine what a sky
with several stars like our sun would
look like
this mind-boggling sight is straight
from a world of fantasy
but that's what we would see if we were
to find ourselves in the caster system
in this film i have told you about many
notable exoplanets
still our trip is admittedly quite brief
to cover all the fascinating worlds
mankind is now aware of
would literally take infinite time even
as we speak about
them the rate at which we get
information about them
grows incrementally it is these unusual
exoplanets
that draw the attention of the entire
scientific community
and it is these celestial bodies that
will become new
objects of more detailed investigations
and research
and so we'll definitely be getting back
to them in our new videos
to bring you the latest updates
[Music]
you